hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
as always we have a new event which
means we have a new event loot video so
you already get the deal we're gonna be
talking about how to get all the loot
the fastest within the new event so we
cannot waste any time we get all that
gear that we want for whatever it
happens to be for the specific character
you want or for everyone in the cast but
what that like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started with today's video now if I am
correct I do believe there is a battle
outfit a ornaments and a new effect
coming in with this new event there is
no weapons this time but everything in
this event is going to be lootable
except the music emotes if you're here
for the music emotes you will have to
get those wood steel so either whip out
the wallet and buy some or start
grinding and as always I've stated this
all the time the number one way to do
this is with Arcade the current Arcade
Quest is four chapters long and it is
called the leaders of why Verndale where
you fight a can't say 80 on DA raider
and a warden in each of the chapters all
with different modifiers and stuff and
just a simple 1v1 and with a few
modifiers and that's it now of course if
you're watching this video a week from
now this chapter in this arcade quest
might be different but I'm covering this
and the first week so as always if this
is like the second week you're gonna
have to hop in on your own and discover
what it is but honestly I don't think
it's too difficult now like I said this
actual arcade quest is really not that
hard it's just one V once for all before
chapters it's going to be in the same
exact map same exact prerequisites
except the only difference is that the
opponents have different modifiers you
actually get no modifiers throughout the
entire arcade quest the first one you're
gonna be fighting is a warden who deals
more damage when their HP is low the
heavy attacks blind the opponents and
the max health is increased next up is a
raider who has a max health increase and
also gains health on successful attacks
the third is a T on D that has burn
damage on attacks max health is
increased and the attacks drain more
stamina and then the very last one is a
Ken's a 1v1 where the heavy attacks
knocked the opponent down all the
attacks are unblockable and E max health
is also increased now they seem a little
bit overpowered going into a 1v1
throughout all these chapters they have
a bunch of modifiers and you have none
it's really not that hard that's just a
very simple 1v1 they just have but you
know a few quirks to them I managed to
get through this would soon da arguably
a below-average character in about four
minutes and within those four minutes I
think I racked up like six or seven
different effects throughout the entire
thing so this is easily one of the best
options and it has been for ages now
obviously not everybody in the world has
arcade and I understand that your next
two options are pretty much either to be
playing carousel of fire or regular
Dominion and reach game modes I've
tested carousel of fire multiple times
and I've really only gotten two to three
pieces of gear within five to ten minute
games and that's usually it be around
the same that you beginning for Dominion
for each you're gonna be getting a lot
more I believe maybe even close to on
par with arcade but of course breach is
like a 20 minute game so if you want to
suffer through that you totally can
there's really nothing else I can say
about this obviously everybody knows
that arcade is the best so if you do
want to drop that cash on to purchase
the marching fire addition to get arcade
I would definitely do that and if you
don't have the money for it now I would
definitely wait and recommend it to wait
for a sale so that it's a lot cheaper
because arcade well not exactly the
greatest thing in the world is super
helpful for when these events come out
so we get all that gear really really
quickly without spending a shitload of
Steel yeah that's gonna be it for
today's video but I just want to let you
guys know of course the gear that is
coming with this just to reiterate that
one more time it's going to be the
battle outfit it's going to be the
effect and it's also going to be the
ornament it has nothing to do with the
music emotes and then that limited a
time kind of Valentine thing those are
purchasable you have to purchase those
be as always like to be if you do enjoy
guys subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you don't even kept up-to-date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and I've ever saw it enough
they definitely say subscribe the
channel the guys take care have a girls
today and peace out
[Music]
you